it's a very basic question because we
can go you know laundry list of the
nasty crazy things he's done but very
simply
was he a very smart guy like as far as
like anyone around him was like oh he's
really smart that guy knows what he's
doing yeah it's just basic IQ and basic
you know education well you've had a mix
of responses right in the since since he
became Infamous of people being like
yeah he was really smart and then other
people being like no he was just a
schmoozer and charismatic and that was
it and he just Bamboozled people and I
think the latter is sort of um people
trying to go back and rewrite history to
an extent I think he was very good at I
mean obviously he graduated from high
school really young but I think uh he
his real you know knack for Stuff had to
do with his you know Financial abilities
let me just put it to this way you're
not going to get away for this long if
you're not smart or even there's a
better word for it the uh not cunning
it's conniving you know uh uh you know
where you can get away with you know
manipulating people for this long yeah
yeah there's Brilliance there he had a
skill set that made people a lot of
money a lot of money and that's part of
why he got away with this for so long so
let's the skill set you're talking about
is sex blackmail is that what you're
talking about I think that's part of it
but as far as as it comes to to Jeffrey
Epstein it looks like that sex blackmail
angle didn't really start until the
early 90s and this is a person we're
talking about Epstein in the 70s right
now then there's the whole question mark
of the 1980s and Jeffrey Epstein and I
would say that
um like I mentioned earlier the
financial crime angle is just as
important as the sex crime mango with
Epstein and it's also the least explored
when you're talking about this guy so
what what do we not know what do we not
know about the 80s okay so he leaves
bear Stearns I sort of mentioned there
was this insider trading investigation
all of that and then Epstein goes on to
claim that he's a financial Bounty
Hunter that's his term for it and
there's numerous quotes and mainstream
media of people that knew Epstein that
were told during this period that he was
a person who claimed to find or hide
money for powerful people
so he's either finding money that was
looted or he's helping people hide
looted money so right there you know
that he's involved in some sort of
Financial gray area and that he has a
very good working knowledge of the
Offshore Banking system
I mean that we can deduce from that
right I think that's pretty so how does
that how does that help him so it's a
financial Bounty okay I get that but the
Bounty people I know they're he calls
himself a bounty hunter a financial
Bounty Hunter that's he's used that
terminology before you're saying yeah
yeah this isn't mainstream media yeah a
financial Bounty Hunter there's only a
handful of ways you're able to get that
but either way whether you're helping
people find money that was stolen or
helping people hide their stolen money
you know where that money goes and this
you know the the lam Labyrinth of where
that money is hidden you know it better
than anyone and that's why people go to
you so so so the blackmail part is the
creative one so uh in the insurance
industry there's something called
premium financing in premium financing
cases pay a lot of commissions we're
talking five you know 10 million dollars
of commissions one guy is doing a
premium financing case with a big
billionaire guy and I'm not going to
tell the story of who's who but he takes
the client away from the competitor
so the competitor who was about to close
this case is going to get paid five
something million dollars is upset and
says you got to give this client to me
because it's mine the other guy's like
I'm not going to take the client I'm not
going to give the client he says no
problem he has three people that work
for him all drop dead gorgeous girls
they go and investigate because a lot of
times these successful people they eat
at the same place they sit at the same
place so it's easy to find them he goes
creates an environment where the girl
it's the same script she's going through
a husband beating all this stuff and she
she says I'm so sorry sits at the same
place at the bar eventually invites him
back to his room her room they go
upstairs they do what they do he leaves
the videotapes the the insurance guy
sends to the other guy says if you don't
give me my client back this is going to
your wife to your clients to your
employees to everybody so this is
something as weird as it sounds this is
not a abnormal thing this goes on quite
often yeah in these circles specifically
so no knowing what you know when you
call yourself a financial Bounty Hunter
have you been able to investigate and
see what his methods were to get the
money back unfortunately it's super
murky there's very little we do know but
for what we do know it is pretty
interesting so it seems like Epstein
during this period had some sort of
relationship with a banknot as a bank of
credit and commerce International BCCI
uh according to the BCCI report which is
a U.S Senate report BCCI was involved in
sex trafficking of minors
apparently for VIPs and other people
whatever that means I don't know but
some of them were prepubescent and this
is coming straight from the Senate
report right very underexplored aspect
of this case if the more you look at
BCCI it seems like you know it was
nominally a bank a Development Bank but
really it's um
um to me sort of more like a price was a
private intelligence apparatus sort of
masquerading as a bank a lot of
intelligence involvement from the
beginning apparently Pakistani
intelligence but there was also you know
reports in Newsweek going decades back
of course because BCCI imploded in 1991
saying that the CIA had some sort of
role in in creating BCCI and was very
involved in money laundering and all
other sorts of stuff this particular
bank and Stephen hoffenberg who was a
mentor to Jeffrey Epstein at some point
later in the 1980s has said that Jeffrey
Epstein had a relationship with this
bank and we know from people like um
Vicki Ward for example that during this
you know Financial Bounty Hunter phase
one of Epstein's main clients was admin
khashoggi the Arms Dealer who had a
relationship with many intelligence
agent khashoggi as in Jamal khashoggi
the journey they're related wow yeah
crazy how this web yeah I mean these at
least very nuts yeah um but I don't know
if I necessarily you know am qualified
to talk about the Jamal khashoggi case
uh but yeah but just these names that
keep popping up yeah Bill Barr what does
he have to do with this journalist
Clinton Trump this well the intelligence
thing being confirmed from someone like
Alex Acosta was told Epstein belonged to
intelligence and you're talking about
all these names they have all these
different intelligence affiliations it
starts to become clear there's something
much deeper to the Epstein case that you
know mainstream media isn't interested
in Touching at all so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]